police in Southern California are
grappling with major loss
one month after 12 people were killed in
a mass shooting at a bar in Thousand
Oaks California in the midst of their
rapid response a mistake was made that
cost the life of a police officer
Jamie yuccas has more this news is
extremely difficult for all of us to
process and understand it was a
gut-wrenching revelation we knew
previously that sergeant ron Heelys ran
into gunfire and had been shot multiple
times Friday came the announcement that
the hero who saved lives was killed by
friendly fire I'm deeply saddened to
inform you that sergeant Heelys was also
struck by a sixth bullet which we now
know through forensic analysis by the
FBI's Crime Laboratory was fired from
the CHP officers rifle even though
sergeant Heelys was wearing body armor
that bullet struck him in the heart
both men charged into the borderline bar
and grill at the same time and were
immediately ambushed by the shooter who
had already killed 11 others
thousands turned out to pay respects to
sergeant Heelys who left behind a son
and a wife of 31 years as for the
California Highway Patrol officer
officials say he learned it was his
bullet just Thursday was a surprised all
of us he's devastated he's a consummate
professional well-trained military
background the mere thought of something
like this happening is devastating to
all of us poor sworn to protect and to
save lives the California Highway Patrol
officer is still on duty both agencies
say it's the gunman who's ultimately
responsible Jamie yuccas CBS News Los
Angeles such tough news for the police
department there but I mean he's still a
hero he is and they put their lives on
the line to save others and in being
there he did just that they can only
prepare so much when they walk in there
and risk their lives absolute chaos
those are chaotic situations devastating